recall that the effect of running any
function with the keyword new is that
that function runs as if it had a bit of
extra code in it particularly it's going
to set the keyword this to equal some
brand new Li created object just because
we ran the van function with the keyword
new and created another different object
does not mean that the other function is
going to run with that same object as
its context these are two different
object create statements that are being
inserted into two different functions as
a result of two different appearances of
the keyword new in the diagram this
would mean that any time you run the van
function with or without the keyword new
it would have the effect of building a
brand new object that delegates to the
constructor of the car class if you're
running the van function with the
keyword new to begin with then you've
already got a brand new object and you
don't need a second one sometimes people
try to solve this by assigning the
result of the new car invocation this
object that gets created during the car
constructor assigning it to the local
keyword this but not only is it
disallowed to assign to the keyword this
at all in your own code even though the
interpreter is allowed to do such things
it doesn't solve the fact that you wind
up having two different objects one of
which you would apparently be throwing
away so this solution just doesn't work
simple enough what if we were to call
the car function without the keyword new
perhaps that would have the effect of
simply running the car function in the
context that we wanted unfortunately
this doesn't work either in this
situation what would you expect the
keyword this from within the car
function to be referring to as a result
of being invoked on this line